well let's move on to some America's Got
Talent news because start on Monday
while they are taking it to the next
level as their Champions returned Simon
is so smart because you know he doesn't
only just want to see the best of the
best in America he wants to see the best
of the best in the world so I mean ah
this is what we're going to call the
Olympics of talents I mean former Got
Talent acts from around the planet
collide and the winter edition of
America's Got Talent
the champions signing season wearing the
same clothes amongst the past
competitors taking the stage again the
international phenom from Britain's Got
Talent
Susan Boyle
[Music]
very sweet lady very sweet lady yeah
and this boy comes out which is Method
Susan I can't think of any contestant
who has defined this show better than
you are you judging them a little
harsher because they've done this before
yeah I did that someone the other day
who wasn't very happy to say the least
[Music]
replacing host Tyra Banks this season
korklan 99s Terry Crews did Tyra give
you any pointers on having to do with
all that no you know what I actually did
not try to get any pointers that way
from Nick or tire that's both good
friends of mine but I wanted to bring
what I was gonna bring you know what I
mean I was born for this show
DGC Terry's got confidence I like that
[Music]